Candace Cameron Beret unfollows her
on-screen sister Jody Sweetin I really
don't think anyone can truly understand
what a family we were yeah but the 90s
are over and perhaps so is the sisterly
bond between these two after Candace
unfollowed Jody on Instagram
and by all appearances it's on account
of Jody's support for Jojo siwa let's
recap that controversy that's what is
amazing about social media earlier this
month Candice revealed the Great
American Family Network where she serves
as Chief creative officer has no plans
to feature same-sex couples she told wsj
magazine that the new Christian
conservative network will keep
traditional marriage at the core our
words matter and that comment kicked off
plenty of backlash including from Jojo I
he can't handle fake people who said
Candace's statement was rude and called
it hurtful to a whole community of
people quote honestly I can't believe
after everything that went down just a
few months ago that she would not only
create a movie with intention of
excluding lgbtqia plus but then also
talk about it in the Press it's been
quite a series of Life events that we've
all shared and Jody offered support to
Jojo noting in the comments you know I
love you E.T reached out to Candace and
Jody's Reps for comment and we should
mention Jody still follows Candace and
her daughter Natasha she's definitely
worked her hardest and just kind of
stood her ground of course this also
came after JoJo seemingly settled her
beef with Candace back in July so I was
finally able to talk to Jojo this
morning after she named the Full House
star on Tick Tock as the rudest
celebrity she ever met
and um we had a great conversation we
had all the feels and it was all good
and there was like there's no drama
that's the T meanwhile Natasha's stuck
by her mom Natasha I'm so proud of her
calling the media a vile space for
negativity before applauding her mom for
how she handles herself with the utmost
Grace when her words are taken out of
context I love having conversations with
people who have differing opinions than
me in the wake of Candace's Firestorm
the actress shared a lengthy statement
on social media
you just have to scroll past it and get
over it she didn't explain why the
network won't feature same-sex couples
but said quote I am called to love all
people and I do adding I had also
expressed in my interview which was not
included that people of all ethnicities
and identities have and will continue to
contribute to the network in great ways
both in front of and behind the camera
which I encourage and fully support
[Music]
thank you